a man accused in a series of sexual
assaults appears in court the eight news
now investigators first reported he had
just agreed to a plea deal and then was
accused of two new crimes Vanessa Murphy
the only reporter in court today to
follow the case against Levante Stuckey
while police say they're looking for
more potential victims of Levante
Stuckey technically he could be released
from jail if he can post a two hundred
thousand dollar Bond Lavonte Stuckey
Levante Stuckey appearing in court
Wednesday on the latest criminal charges
he faces one of three cases against the
19-year-old man all involving alleged
sex crimes against women the first in
July a woman told police Stuckey held
her against her will in a car demanded
sex acts and claimed he had a gun in
November Stucky pleaded guilty to false
imprisonment and received credit for
time served the second case in December
after a woman who said she's a sex
worker reported Stuckey's sexually
assaulted her near the Orleans also
locking her in the car and demanding sex
acts and the third case after police say
a third victim also a sex worker reached
out to detectives later that month with
a story Sim similar to the first two
victims in court Stucky tries to cover
his face but police already released his
booking photo to reach out to other
potential victims his next court date is
set for February 8th judge already gave
you bail at 100 000 you have a hundred
thousand on the other one all right so
we have two cases
um and we're gonna set these I'm Gonna
Keep the public defender on it the judge
saying Stuckey's two most recent cases
will likely be Consolidated into one
reporting at the Regional Justice Center
in downtown Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8
news now and police are asking anyone
with any information to call the number
on your screen 702-828-3455